un coup de gueule qu'est ce qui se passe
non mais notre ami raquel a remis le
couvert
raquel garrido va rappeler elle doit
venir nous voir un prochainement elle un
jour ça m'étonnerait elle a posté un
tweet ou elle a donc de nouveau parler
de football en réclamant à cause d'un
plan social que castorama soit hors de
la ligne j'ai envie de dire pourquoi pas
oui sauf que castorama né paul sponsor
de la ligue 1 c'est conforama je veux
bien
je veux bien qu'on se mobilise contre un
plan social mais comprennent pas encore
le foot là dedans parce que alors sinon
c'est la ligue 1 à lens
ikea vous êtes moquer de labour day et
bientôt la digue à ikea la ligue 1 but
la digue droit vers la ligue 1 roche
bobois une championne et raquel garrido
vous a bien sûr répondu ah on attendait
votre réaction avec impatience je suis
déçu je vous aurais coûtent plus
mordants la prochaine fois peut-être
bisous je ne tire jamais sur les
ambulances est-ce que vous avez répondu
et faire quand j'ai des têtes de turcs
je m'arrange pour être seul dans le foot
quand il a une tête de turc à l'est qu'à
moi et ben jawad à evra mais vous quand
même
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu très
calme c'est bon les séries merci affirmé
m
ça c'était sait tous